[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un cowboy qui coupe
du bois pour l'hiver
un indien passe par là et le cow boy lui
demande
dis-moi grand chef indien il fera froid
cet hiver et l'un répond hivers froids
bon le cow boy se remettent à couper du
bois
le jour suivant l'indien repasse et le
cow boy lui demande c'est l'hiver sera
aussi froid qu'on le dit l'indien répond
hiver très froid
on a là le cowboy ils stressent donc il
reprend sa scie et une coupe une
montagne de bois le lendemain
l'indien repasse par là et en voyant le
gros sabots à dix hivers très très froid
il y en a marre il m'attend mais grand
chef indien
comment sais tu que l'hiver sera aussi
froid et l'indien répond chez nous il ya
un dicton quand l'homme blanc coup
beaucoup de bois l'hiver sera très froid
le rapport à la nature est avant tout un
rapport culturel
la question de l'agriculture et plus
largement de la nature est toujours
considéré par les relations avec son
contexte
autrement dit parler de la nature n'est
jamais qu'une manière de parler de soi
de se situer au sein du vivant dans
notre talk l'agriculture ne va pas nous
intéresser en tant que tel mais par les
relations avec son contexte
nous portons donc notre regard sur les
évolutions de l'agriculture avec les
évolutions de la société de la
perception de la nature avec
principalement une vision occidentale
alors pour la suite je vais avoir besoin
de mon père vous avez vu on a respecté
la distanciation physique puisqu'il a
plus de dix mille kilomètres d'ici sur
l'île de la réunion
et oui ciment ce que j ai appris de la
vie mon fils c'est que lorsque nous
parlons de changement de rupture
nous ne pouvons pas rester aux simples
changements de procéder en surface il
faut aller au plus profond au système de
leur sous jacent il n'y a pas de
changement de pratique sans un
changement de paradigme associés sans
une nouvelle représentation une nouvelle
lecture du monde et à chaque rupture
la large de schopenhauer se vérifie il
est d'abord considéré comme ridicule
puis dangereux et enfin évident déclaré
que la terre était ronde à d'abord été
une pensée moquer ridiculiser plus on
l'a considérée comme dangereuse alors on
a brûlé les hérétiques pour enfin
accepté de manière évidente
notre modeste place au sein de notre
galaxie infinie ridicule dangereux
évident aujourd'hui nous allons prendre
appui sur la spirale dynamique qui est
un méta modèle décrivant les ruptures
dans les systèmes de valeurs nous allons
distingué huit rupture 8 paradis guînes
niveau de conscience humaine qui
détermine notre rapport à la réalité
je les ai vécus par les entreprises est
une dira si non comment tu observes dans
le monde de l'agriculture et notre
rapport à la nature
quels sont donc ces huit niveaux
d'existence débutons donc l'histoire au
paléolithique homo sapiens héberge 120
mille ans avant jésus-christ recherche
de nourriture
réaction instinctive aux tensions ce
premier niveau d'existence du beige
n'existe plus aujourd'hui sauf parfois à
l'issue de grandes catastrophes
naturelles arrive alors un deuxième
niveau d'existence dit violée
un monde effrayant rempli de pouvoir
mystérieux nous sommes cinquante mille
ans avant jésus-christ la pensée et
animiste on croire des esprits magique
alors pour assurer sa sécurité ont fait
appel aux anciens au chef au sharan pour
vivre en harmonie avec les pouvoirs
magiques de la nature ce niveau lyonnais
existe encore de nos jours lorsque nous
faisons appel aux rituels aux traditions
aux coutumes aux superstitions
mais les organisations devenant trop
clanique avec trop de rituels étouffant
on faire émerger un troisième niveau
d'existence le monde rouge
expression de ma puissance autonome
impulsivité égocentrique affirmation
héroïque
je ne vous parle pas de donald trump
mais du monde rouge qui a démarré dix
mille ans avant jésus-christ le monde
est vu comme une jeune plein de menaces
et de prédateur alors il faut dominer
conquérir sans regret ni remords
la pratique est très simple la loi du
plus fort mais conquérir sans bâtir
quel sens à tout cela va alors émerger
un quatrième niveau d'existence le monde
bleu la période bleue démarre deux mille
cinq cents ans avant jésus-christ on
croit dans un monde contrôlé par une
vérité ultime qui publie ou récompenses
il s'agit de sacrifier le soin pour
obtenir une récompense plus tard de
réprimer son impulsivité et au nom d'une
culpabilité qui frappera celui qui
transgresse c'est la base de nos
anciennes nations des organisations
politiques et religieuses mais aussi de
nos entreprises avec leur hiérarchie
rigide parfois paternaliste on va voir
avec toi ciment dans un instant comment
s'exprime cette verticalité dans le
monde agricole
mais avant cela un bon alors là c'est le
moment où je le mets en muse parce que
je le connais sinon on en aurait pour 15
minutes
récapitulons d'abord les quatre premiers
systèmes de valeurs en gros beige c'est
comme dans l'âge de glace 1 les peuples
sont nomades ils se déplacent au gré de
leurs besoins
ils chassent cueille et pêche côté
agriculture on n'y pense même pas on
arrive en violet le paradigme violé la
représentation du monde en violet c'est
de percevoir la nature comme une
divinité avec des esprits pouvant
apporter des malédictions
alors côté sécurité savoir que des dieux
veille en permanence sur nous c'est un
petit côté rassurant des éclairs dans le
ciel c'est the le castex de l'époque qui
n'est pas content et qui le fait savoir
aucune question à se poser les mythes
ont réponse à tout côté agriculture
toujours rien
on arrive en rouge l'agriculture
apparaît sous des formes primaires dans
quelques régions du globe les hommes
commencent à domestiquer certains
animaux et essai de subvenir à leurs
besoins tout en restant sur leur
territoire la pratique en rouge devient
rapidement le pouvoir et la conquête
on est donc dans la pratique du ici
c'est chez moi et comme sédentarisation
rime avec accroissement de la population
et surexploitation des terres les hommes
partent en quête de terrains plus
fertiles on arrive en bleu bleu c'est la
mise sur orbite de la révolution du
néolithique démarré en violet c'est une
déflagration majeure dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
c'est la naissance de l'agriculture
jusque là nos aïeux chasseurs cueilleurs
avait beau avoir une intelligence proche
de la nôtre
ils n'ont pas su faire société au sens
où nous l'entendons aujourd'hui établir
un contrat social
il a fallu une idée nouvelle pour
prendre possession de la nature
maîtrisée son alimentation et pouvoir
rester sur son territoire c'est avant
tout un changement culturel
oui mais on va remettre mon père parce
que je le connais il aime pas être en
mieux trop longtemps bon alors si je ne
suis plus en août je vais pouvoir
poursuivre avec le cinquième niveau
d'existence dit orange
ce n'est plus au quai de rester dans le
rang comme en bleu alors qu'on pourrait
avoir une part du gâteau bien plus
grande
avoir du succès de l' influence par son
monde perçu comme plein de ressources et
d'opportunités pour se créer une vie
plus prospères en orange
il ya une recherche d'abondance
d'autonomie de progrès par la
technologie
les organisations deviennent plate
matricielle c'est le management de la
performance mais trop de performance et
puis le système épuise les ressources
humaines et fait émerger un sixième
niveau d'existence divers il y à
quelques décennies
lippert consommateurs individualiste en
excès du stade précédent se réapproprie
les émotions lettre la spiritualité dans
un monde perçu comme
mita commun de l'humanité c'est entre
autres le monde des hippies des années
70 tu n'as pas connu sinon j'ai encore
quelques photos compromettantes dans les
organisations en ajoute hop et deux
profils ep de people et le p2 planète
le leader hiérarchique bleus est devenu
délai gatif en orange et associatif
envers mes crocs de collaboratif là
encore faire émerger un septième niveau
d'existence dit jaune
il débute il ya 20 30 ans le monde est
perçu comme un ensemble de systèmes
complexes dont il faut assurer le la
viabilité alors que le monde échange en
plein d'incertitudes en jaune
on se réapproprie le savoir la
compétence individuelle la pensée
complexe n'en duels aucun individu
aucune organisation qu'une société ne
peut s'affranchir de cheminée dans ses
différentes étapes de cette spirale
comme une quête sans fin
on parle d'ailleurs déjà d'un huitième
niveau d'existence dit turquoise que ne
le décrit rompt pas aujourd'hui donc
dans les organisations où s'en passer
d'un monde bleu verticale hiérarchique à
monde jaune aux équipes autonome en
réseau et toi cindy nous dans le monde
agricole et tu prends ton kif pour nous
amener vers l'agriculture jaune
tout à fait alors avant ça revenons
quand même sur le monde
orange qui voit émerger le paradigme du
progrès exploité et performer et bien ça
se retrouve dans les pratiques on parle
d'exploitation agricole on perçoit la
nature comme un obstacle on arrache les
arbres les et zélés et pour gagner
quelques mètres carrés
et puisqu'on est dans un monde très
scientifique
ce n'est pas étonnant que la solution se
soit la chimie donc en pratique on
utilise des produits en side
insecticides fongicides herbicides
mais n'oublions pas que c'était perçu
comme un progrès à une époque où il
fallait nourrir une population de plus
en plus nombreuses et qui avait subi
deux guerres mondiales mais le trop du
orange exploitent les ressources
naturelles et fait émerger le monde
r envers le paradigme la vision du monde
c'est de se reconnecter à la nature
l'être humain a réappris à se mettre à
l'écouté de soi
il se met ainsi plus facilement aller
coûte de son environnement
le monde verts remettent en question les
pratiques de l'agriculture dite
conventionnelle
ça se traduit par l'émergence de
l'agriculture biologique dans les années
1970 qui se posent aux produits en side
donc en pratique on passe du produit
phytosanitaire aux produits biologiques
le vert c'est naturel
mais rapidement le le concept de spirale
dynamique c'est que le trot d'un monde
ont fait émerger un autre le trop de
l'exploitation et de la chimie fait
émerger le monde vers des ressources
naturelles et vous vous en doutez
rapidement aussi le vert et dans le trop
surtout lorsqu'il s'inscrit en
opposition systématique au monde
orange pour aboutir parfois à ce qu'on
appelle les khmers verts on arrive en
jaune moment de préférer le paradigme
jaune c'est de vouloir produire avec le
vivant et je dirais même que c'est de
vouloir produire du vivant et ce
paradigme de reconnexion aux vivants
passe en plus par s'inspirer de celui ci
de faim de bien l'analyser pour mieux
s'en inspirer le monde jaune intègre du
monde orange et vert et les transcende
on dépasse alors la dualité l'opposition
classique entre hommes et animaux pour
considérer l'espèce humaine comme
appartenant au vivant au même titre que
toutes les autres et pour faire face aux
multiples défis
on veut une agriculture qui régénère nos
écosystèmes qui va les à grade et on
veut alors une agriculture du vivant qui
se soucie de ses animaux et de leur
bien-être mais aussi des bactéries des
insectes des champignons et de tous les
autres micro organismes présents dans
les sols dans le monde agricole actuelle
jaune c'est l'agroécologie qui s'est
défini par une façon de concevoir des
systèmes de production paradigme en
s'appuyant sur les fonctionnalités
offertes par ces écosystèmes pratique
s'est défini dans la loi et c'est une
science on protège en vert on protège et
ont produit en jaune alors prenons un
exemple pour illustrer le paradigme
jaune qu'est ce qui structure le mieux
le sol entre ces deux propositions
alors je vous donnais un petit indice
quelques petits indices c'est celui qui
va créer des galeries dans le sol
structurer sa composition ingéré de la
matière organique
c'est un lait un élément clé dans la
fertilité des sols
c'est bien entendu le ver de terre et
pour laisser bosser tranquille
ces vers de terre eh bien on réduit
voire suppriment le travail du sol
les ferments mais en permaculture l ont
bien compris qu'il fallait changer de
paradigme avant de changer de pratique
la permaculture c'est avant tout une
philosophie une vision du monde avant
d'être une pratique bon pour résumer
brièvement les trois derniers monde
le paradigme orange exploite la nature
le paradigme vers la protègent et le
monde jaune protège et produit du vivant
et si tels sont leurs paradigmes alors
les pratiques associées sont que le
monde orange utilise la chimie le monde
vers le biologique et le monde jaune
pense de manière systémique
je crois qu'il est temps d'arriver au
résumé les trois messages clés que l'on
voulez vous faire passer le premier
temps qu'il n'y a pas de changement de
pratique sans changement de paradigme
que le changement de paradigme précède
le changement de pratique c'est vrai
dans la vie des organisations mon père
l'a expliqué c'est vrai dans la vie
sociétale et évidemment le monde
agricole n'y échappe pas il faut
toutefois préciser que un changement de
pratique peut amener aussi un changement
de paris
le deuxième message c'est que à chaque
nouveau système de valeurs il est
d'abord perçu comme ridicule puis
dangereux avant d'être évident et si
nous voulons passer à cette agriculture
jaune il faudra considérer qu'il n'est
ni ridicule ni dangereux de faire
converger les agricultures orange et les
agricultures du monde vert dans la
synthèse du monde john et pour ce faire
combinez judicieusement d'une part une
capacité d'écouté d'analystes
d'inspiration de la nature avec d'autre
part une connaissance scientifique
agronomique technique extrêmement
poussée et le dernier message c'est que
si jamais vous chercher le bonheur et
bien il se trouve dans le vers de terre
et ça je crois que c'est mon père qui
voulait vous le rappeler bon allez je
viens de maintes années en arrière quand
tu es dans ton lit avec ton doudou jaune
et que je te jure 17 chansons qui a vu
dans la rue du mené
le petit ver de terre qui a vu dans la
rue tout menu le petit verre tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]